hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast high efficiencies fry
technology from micro RNA applications
presented by dr. Denali we are excited
to bring you this educational web
seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by beckman coulter genomics
beckman coulter genomics headquartered
in Danvers Massachusetts sets the
standard for providing expert next
generation and sanger sequencing
services with file automatically shins
life science health care businesses as
well as academic and government
institutions worldwide rely on deck
medical genomics to deliver the highest
quality data robust analyses and
innovative thinking from classic to
cutting-edge second quarter genomics has
proven experience and expertise on a
wide range of technology platforms every
associate at beckman coulter genomics is
dedicated to delivering total customer
service to learn more about our sponsor
please visit www.fcn genomics com I'm
Brenda Kelly Kim of Lavery's phenom be a
moderator for today's event before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive and we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation just
click on the green Q&A button located in
lower left the presentation window and
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of our presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in a slide window you need
to enlarge this just click on the screen
icon located at the lower body finally
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing these presentation please let us
know by clicking on the support button
at the top right of the presentation
handle or you can use the Q&A button to
let us know you're having the problem
lower left now i'd like to offer our
audience to join me in welcoming dr.
guna me dr. Bellamy has worked at
beckman coulter life sciences for five
years but she is responsible for leading
micro RNA and RNA applications she has
10 years of experience and genomic and
genetics research she has a PhD in
microbiology and molecular biology in
Texas A&M University it's a postdoctoral
fellow at harvard medical school
sponsored by the Athenian Society of
America the research experience was in
the fields of humble biology cell signal
small molecules and plan pathogenicity
for more information about dr. Lee
please click on our name to see what dr.
Lee I'm going to turn it over to you now
hi hi good morning my name is Ben Ali
I'm an application scientist from
beckman coulter life sciences my copy
for my presentation today is high
efficiency sprite technology for Michael
I'm a and iono applications here is my
outline first I will give you a brief
introduction on sprite technology
sprites thanks for solid-phase reversed
in normalizations i will describe how we
optimized hours right chemistry for my
kalila expression using the farm of your
kids for the formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissues i will then
show you the comparison result soon
between the farm field kids versus a
common color kit in the second half of
my tops i will be described to you the
method development for micro a
enrichment using our sprite solutions so
normally I was right Pam and edit bit
silly you create a purification kits
come with a lysis buffer containing
protein escaped a binding buffer and
wash buffer here is the typical basic
three basic steps of a sprite procedure
in the first step you just need to enter
your cell lysis to the magnetic beads
nucleus II within draw and bound
the magnetic beads in the presence of
running battle with the clowning
reagents the contaminant will then
remove by wash buffer and multiple Akana
washes ups it would then irritate you
using the ps3 water so it allows you to
have a maximum flexibility in the
downstream applications as you can see
here that spy procedure does not require
any certifications or filtration straps
and it allows Fred automation friendly
procedure most of you probably very
familiar with our of PCR cleanup and
next-gen sequencing cleanup kits such as
ampio XP I would like to use this
opportunity to highlight our DNA and RNA
expression tips using our spray
chemistry we have a kid steps for the
cell culture tissues blood samples serum
and plasma today I'm going to focus on
the farm appealed kids for the FFPE
samples here are the different options
that we provide the automations
workstation for genomic applications for
nucleic acid communications and next-gen
sequencing library constructions it
depends on your troopers and your
application so we can offer and provide
multiple configurations for the
automation workstations to fit your
application needs
I just want to give you this in example
is how easy to use using our bow Max's
right its user interface all you need is
to just click the green buttons and then
you can choose how many rules are simple
you like to run around and the bow shock
wave will will then pop out this user
interface it will give you how many two
boxes what kind of every type is
required for the runs and then the
reagent calculator is very friendly used
usage it allows you to have a mini mark
that volumes and also prevent any
handling errors throughout the your
procedures so the question we ask is can
Beckman's the spark chemistry be used
for my clarinet extractions most of us
will know about what micro RNA why it is
important micro RNA are stable very
stable non-korean when horny clearances
it's very small fragments around 22
nucleotides and a single my client can
target several up to 100 thousands of
genes and regulations that gene can
involve in multiple pathways and
signaling pathway and disease
development it is our desire to and also
other research is designed to use about
micro RNAs biomarkers for this
development and use it as a potential
therapeutic targets just want to use
this line to show you how we optimize
our protocols for my client extraction
using our farm appeal kids we basically
optimizing each suspect see in the arrow
here in the binding steps watching step
and different ethical watching stats
here shows the experimental designs so
we use one microgram of 22 audio UK
title as the test tempos and then we
determine what's the best binding
refining rush conditions for my corn a
recovery the recovery amount with end
major by nano drugs and also visualized
by our chilled once we optimize our
protocols we then use the protocol for
the real simple extraction in this case
we use attacking samples we then major
the micron expression by using the tech
men's rt-qpcr microwave a micro RNAs a
here's the results the Europe 22 audio
nucleotides flew by using different
concentration of running buffer and for
each of the test conditions we use su 1
microgram of 22 of oligonucleotides we
then alluded in 40 micro regional water
and if you the recovery which which is
harder to st. we expect to get 25 a gram
per microliter so with that I want to
show you the result in here that the
link to is the control and purified 22
all in all in good time with locally
fine and great plains name one is the
temp DNA starts Markel let it land mine
are the different conditions of the
binding buffer and I want to you to
focus on lane another line the condition
line goodnight attic give us pretty much
it 100% recovering as compared to the
control samples we then fix the planning
prefer using the condition number nine
similarly we use the same strategy to
optimize the Washington
and repairing conditions I just want to
show you the one up except and other
examples in here that one microgram are
22 audio nucleotides we will use as the
test sample and then it look it in the
same volumes 40 micro liters and then
you can see here that Lane us with a
fixed binding condition we now optimized
the watching conditions and I want you
to focus on lane seven five seven and
eight they both give the highest yield
under these conditions so we decided to
use the condition file for the further
text because this volume was used for
the four for the length condition number
five so once we optimize the binding
refining washing conditions we then use
the protocol for the real simple
extractions and to confirm rehabil Mike
Warren lyric re we use the light seven
genes as our target gene to look at the
micro RNA expressions for that we use
the tissue control with the 50 nanogram
per reactions and then for the FFPE
extract RNA we they use one to find
Michael eaters and then we follow the
real our technologies to reverse
transcriptase and the master magnet use
Universal master mix for the PCR
reactions here's the the qpcr our
results in the amplification part showed
that the less 17 micro RNA was
successfully extricate is minor and
manually it's like it ffe samples and
the control you can see the FFPE capote
give you one cycle courier expressions
as compared to the tissue control
we then almost hour manually extracted
protocol to the biomat automation
extraction methods and hear what you see
here is the amplification platform the
12 given FFPE samples extracted from the
biomech automation two methods the
average city cycle was about 23.5 we
then compare the RNA you are between the
vomitus automation expressions with the
manually extra gifts are named here the
graph shows you that the 48 samples the
average for the examples of prepared
from each methods we show that our maker
ultimate automatic expression give a
higher sorry higher learning yields as
compared to the Mary extricate simple
and we believe this is because to the
automation suit preparations you have a
very consistent of the pipetting and
less speed boost to other procedures and
we then look at the RNA recoveries
compared to comparing the does honest
and poke we pay for the vomit automation
process to manually extricate samples
the left graph show you the let-7 my
corner gene expression we actually look
at a different micron lining and just
show you the less 17 which is the
universal my coronate express in most of
the tissues and you can see that the
hope you can see this is the less noise
vomit and then the right sorry it's the
menu it's very simple they both get race
of comparable of micro RNA expression
suit our recovery and then the right cut
like I'll show you the messenger RNA
expression so we look at it also
multiple housekeeping genes and here i
show you the acting and abbott ome gene
expression then compared to the bar Mac
versus the manually express example we
show that the full methods give me very
comparable messenger gene expressions
with the same input for the iron amount
in the reactions we never have to be the
next few on slice I'm going to switch
girl to talk about we compare the okapi
case versus the mi easy columns so we
extracted the RNA from the human
different cover human tissue the word
breast and the column tissue atrophy
samples and from home protocols we then
measure it and look at the honor you and
purity and then we also look at the iron
quality using the pickle chips violin
risers pickle chips and we make it a
requiring expression using the
microlenses with a different
concentration of RNA and here so the
result of the honor yields so for each
protocol we expected four slices of 10
micron of epi FFPE samples and you can
see that the average E and it will
irritate the the RNA with the same
volume 40 micro levels so here shows
that we the farm kid protocols the
average concentration is about 257
nanogram per microliter the yield is
about chemical in for the 40 micro
needles and then average after 10 my
concert cause lysis give about 200
micrograms as compared to the mi easy
columns at the average concentrations
about 15 airplanes average hear about
true micrograms with a 25 micrograms
/ 10 microns so we show that that the
ANA yields higher also using the thumb
of your kids we then I look at the RNA
quality inconsistent with a nanodrop
measurement we show that in order to
reach the Little Dipper and sexy and
sensual to analyzer said nozzle for the
form of your kit extracted an example we
have to download try x high yield and in
order to get the same same or similar
signals as compared to the column
extract RNA so as you see that it's one
to ten delusions for the am i easy
Michael unexpected simple and then from
of your kids we did 12 50 televisions we
then look at the micro RNA recoveries so
inconsistent into early observations so
we did the tune concentration for the
party to PCR reactions hundred open vs.
15 aeroplanes based on the nanodrop
management and we expected the week the
qpcr did arguments this seminal CT
values inform Calkins for the Palmetto
print is about twenty three cycles and
then from for the 50 milligrams and
Papas 24 cycles and and look at the
dilution factor for the former pure kids
we have to paddle five times higher
years as compared to the column column
extra tip RNA and so one fifth of the
uncredited from of you expected Anna was
knitted to reach the same cycle valiant
Sony so we sure that if this particular
experiments that the farm of your
kids'll do give us diculous the high
RNA as compared to the college kids so
we then look at the RNA purities
compared to the RNA circuit from these
two methods so they both give us the bow
method deeply comparable high purity in
terms of only 262 the only to a key
ratios and only 262 only 230 ratios the
next few slides i'm going to show you
the clinical are a very simple soon the
unexpected from the clinical are RNA
rapini samples so what if see here is
the 40 circles 20 21 and 20 b93 FFPE
samples from the patients so what the
customer did was they punch the region
of interest based on the pathology
report and they performed the unexpected
expression using other calm appeal by
max methods and as we expected because
this very highly degraded I therapy RNA
samples so we get the high arrangement
between 400 26 micrograms 400 milligrams
or 6 micro microwaves of RNA and then we
use this 40 samples within our we then
we'll use these 40 samples for the CD
cDNA library construction for the next
gen sequencing and again as we expected
because the dynamic range of the RNA
qualities we got though the sitting in
our be here from the 15 and 12 1.8 about
1.8 micrograms
and then but when you look at the cdna
very quiet he actually it's not it's
pretty decent we were able to get
sitting re range from 200 to 400 we then
I'll pick up the three pair of the tumor
and be night samples for the next gen
sequencing you mean our next I'm
sequencing for the Illuminati next-gen
sequencing and what I look at here is we
compared to the manually extracted
library compared to the bomber at
prepare library and you can see very
good correlation between the tumor a and
he will be the tamari and a sample and
sympathy for this other simple see we
see the lower slightly lower
accommodation but it's what we expected
because the other quality was to begin
with was very poor so for the i'll just
show you that the FFPE expected from the
farm he'll get kids give you a good
quality armful on a no so for the lappy
prep and the QC didn't happen i agree we
also look at the latrine expressions i
didn't show you here but we also look at
the three pair of the high highly
expressed low express and medium
expressed genes to compare me to kill
Krishna and they shall make
accommodations and now i'm going to show
you that for the atropine form of your
kids we can use the kids for the Lord
it's simple input such as laser capture
microdissection samples what you see in
this line is the left graph show you the
RNA yo from the three pair of the tumor
and the benign son hosts and a range
from the fifth 15 13 8 30 final burn 270
now 70 final grades and this was
measured by the arrival grim ah SI and
the right panel shows the low signal on
fragmented of ffp RNA extracted from the
LCM samples we then look at the gene
expression data and we saw that the
micro expression was successfully
expected from the LCM Sam posle we don't
get the control and the micro RNA
biomarkers from this light it shows that
non significance the differences between
the timid versus the timber versus the
benign samples so we did I just conclude
that my first part of my talk by the
microwaves essentially showed it hi
Michael on a hill using a um I'm I feel
kids and then it shows good quality of
the cDNA library prints and then it can
be used for the load simple input cell
phone like LCMS and if the biomech
automation method is a simple robots and
automation friendly process so then I
would have a few slides to talk about
how we optimize the protocol for the
micro RNA enrichment so we ask the
question can we isolate micro RNA from
RNA fractions in general information
surprise select was originally optimized
for the developed for the
double-stranded DNA publications and we
asked him using swype select for my
colony in richmond and online site
selection here is the experiment designs
so similarly we're using one microgram
of the 22 and 53 oracle nucleotides used
as a test impose and determine what the
best binding conditions that can
separate the 22 article nucleotides from
predatory oligonucleotides we then major
the the RNA recovery using the nano
drugs and visualized by our job and we
then once we optimize the conditions
within
use the real simple XCOM for the micro
RNA enrichment here showing the recovery
efficiency so what do you see here on
that's the one microgram of 22 and 53
article nucleotides as a input samples
the apple event is the 53 article
nucleotides the roll pin is the 22
article nucleotides Glen ones the DNA
size marker 92 is the control with a 25
milligram of the plate and i want to
point you out to the lens islands the
lens seven conditions can bind to the 22
or even in the taxes more efficiently
than that 53 article in Picard's we then
further optimize the condition I want to
show you in the right panel here I want
you to focus on that girl so we are ever
to further optimize the condition that
allow us to purify 22 nucleotides but
they do not attempt to capture the
cryptic tweet article nucleotides we
then once we optimize the protocol we
then compared to the mineral condom
enrichment protocols and I'm one so we
are so we start with one microgram not
22 with it and 53 oligonucleotides and
then diluted in the same volume what you
see here the length through is the
control sample length three are the spy
protocol the blends take four to six are
the middle little columns protocols I
want you to focus on the three and nine
states because the same amount of the
RNA was loaded on the job and you can
see that the middle columns by to the 22
Oregon [ __ ] Ty's more efficiently than
the 53 Oracle nucleotides in contrast
the middle column protocol by to the
free between article nucleotides more
efficiently than the 22 or even equal
parts you then compared to the land four
and then five it was loaded in the
different
higher among both loaded and you can see
that the obviously that the tele to
article America was captured by with a
less efficiency with the middle column
protocol we then adheres the micro RNA
process overview so in the micro Anna
enrich protocol we have three finding
Stubbs the first steps if I to the enemy
nucleotides over the 200 200
oligonucleotides and then once the that
you can transfer the supernatant to the
new well you apply to the second binding
buffer which binds to the ninety to
two-hundred nucleotides within
transpolar you can transfer the
supernatant to the third world and the
bindings that allow you to recover it
the facts modern fragment size 18 260
new headlights and so he'll show you the
micron the enrichment of results so you
can if you'll follow me with that three
specs so and then when you look at the
result so i will show you that we can
enrich you promote if you combine the
three statuses you allow you to enrich
primarily 18 260 mythic arts and then um
you can skip you can also combine the
first and the second binding steps it
will allow you to be in Richie ninety to
two-hundred article nucleotides can she
the paranoid narcissist result in here
and in the if you if you wish to just
recover 18 to 200 nucleotides you can
skip the second binding stats and it
allows you to recover it
to our new great heights so I'm going
once we optimize the protocol we doing
compared to the real simple extraction
micron in Richmond using the sprite
protocol and middle little column so
this time will show you the average you
of one microgram of the total RNA class
micro RNA and we apply the protocols and
you can see that for the spread
particles when you were able to enrich
e61 percent as compared to the middle
little columns get up Tony in which
about thirty one percent so here's the
bioanalyzer so in which plan conf are
linked for the spy select the protocol
to read in return you can see here that
it when she taking to about 60 new
pickups for the middle column in which
my client from 18 up to 115 month
nucleotides so in summary we show you
the square chemistry demonstrated very
high efficiency micron enrichment and
spread select solutions for a very
flexible mike rwanda in richmond an RNA
site selection [ __ ] as a unfold on a
site selection procedures and we also
show you that us I'm associated as a
sprite chemistry as a very flexible and
a space simple and robot suit automation
for any process so this is my last but
not my leased lines I want to give them
to my collaborators the mäkelä and Vega
from dana farber institutes and I was a
colloidal form UC Davis live on Kim laps
left Randy cedars and
Alicia also entertain our Ragman
colleague Jones and Sarah floor helping
the ballots automation methods and the
Isabel's of help for different type of
sprite did not undergo support with that
I want to thank you you for your
patience and any questions thank you
very much dr. Lee for that informative
presentation let me just give our
audience a second to hear how they need
to submit their questions if you have a
question you like to ask dr. me now is a
great time just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into that box that appears on
your screen click send and really having
a question we're going to give our
audience just a few minutes to find the
question box and put in their questions
let's see what we have
alrighty I'm just going to send it back
to dr e now to see if she has any final
comments for our audience
thank you very much for your attention
if you have any questions so I think we
have the other adult and all
informations on the website and if any
yeah you can contact our website and our
your local sales with into any question
on my presentation thank you again dr.
Lee for your time and of course we'd
like to thank our sponsor button culture
genomics for making this podcast
possible today the bright out want to
let everybody know today's webcast will
be available for replay on demand
through March 2016 you'll receive an
email from lab returning you when this
webcast is available for viewing and we
would invite you to pass that you now
along to your colleagues who may not
have been able to attend today's live
event we will proceed again thank you
for working on today goodbye